good morning I would like to thank Adam
heppenstahl and his team for the
diligence and professionalism they have
shown in compiling today's report
Mr happenstall's View
is that while I did breach the
governance code for public appointments
he States very clearly that a breach
does not necessarily invalidate an
appointment
indeed I've always maintained the breach
was inadvertent and not Material which
the facts he lays out substantiate
the secretary of state has consulted
with the BBC board who support that view
nevertheless I have decided that it is
right to prioritize the interests of the
BBC
I feel that this matter May well be a
distraction from the corporation's good
work were I to remain in post until the
end of my term
I have therefore this morning
resigned as a BBC chair to the Secretary
of State and to the board
it was proposed to me that I stay on his
chair until the end of June while the
process to a point my successor is
undertaken and I will of course do that
in the interests of the corporation's
stability and continuity
let me turn to the events that a subject
of today's report
when I saw it in December 2020 to
introduce the cabinet secretary to Mr
Blythe I did so in good faith
I did so with the best of intentions
and I did so with the sole purpose of
ensuring that all relevant rules were
being followed
I am pleased that Mr heppenstall
supports the fact
that my involvement in these matters as
he States was accordingly very limited
after extensive work he States his words
that he's happy to record that has seen
no evidence and nor could he to say I
played any part whatsoever in
facilitation
arrangement
or financing of a loan to the former
prime minister